[موسيقى]
في الليالي السعيدة ، يمكننا أن نرى
كل شيء تقريبًا في سدم المجرة ، أفضل
شيء يمكنك رؤيته هنا هو طرق مماثلة ، حيث
إنه مشرق للغاية ويمكنك رؤية الكثير
من النجوم المتساقطة ، كما أن بعض الليالي
تكون جيدة جدًا لدرجة أنها من أفضل
الأماكن التي يمكنك مشاهدتها  في العالم
وأفضل جزء في هذا المنظر يأتي مع غرفة
هنا
يقومون بالحجز.
يبدو أن مزيجًا غير متوقع قد تحول
إلى واحد من أغلى
الأماكن في سويسرا ، فقد تم بناء الزخرفة الرائعة
في عام 1907 ، ولا تزال بعض أجزاء
المبنى كما هي
في البداية لدينا 22 غرفة هناك
أربعة أو خمسة أيام في السنة  حيث يوجد
5000 شخص ، إنه أعلى فندق في
سويسرا وثاني أعلى فندق في
أوروبا ، والوجه هنا
هو الجبل الذي يمكنك رؤيته حوله
يوجد Monte Rosa ثم Brigh  تون
والجميع في العالم يعلمون الأمر ،
فنحن نقدم في الغالب طعامًا سويسريًا تقليديًا
جبن مخفوق بالجبن رشدي مع النقانق عليه
وصلصة البصل وأيضًا معكرونة ألفريد ،
إنه أمر مميز حقًا بالنسبة لي
لأنني أحب الجبال هنا
في الليل إنه هادئ للغاية و  السماء
مدهشة حقًا
[موسيقى]
هذه القباب موجودة هنا من الستينيات حتى
الآن ولكن علم الفلك هنا في الجبال
يعود إلى بداية 1900
عالم من جميع أنحاء
العالم إذا كنت تريد القيام بعلم الفلك
فعليك  ظروف
جيدة وهي حقيقة أن أفضل الظروف
التي تعيشها هنا في الجبال
قلة التلوث الضوئي والهواء الجاف
تعني أن الناس مثل جيسي يمكنهم حقًا
مراقبة الفضاء من هنا ولكن حتى
بالعين المجردة
يمكن لأي شخص أن يراقب جمال الليل في
gornergrat  إنها واحدة من أفضل الأماكن التي
كنت على يقين من أنك تخرج منها على
الشرفة وترى هذه الفرقة الضخمة
يا السماء وهي مشرقة جدًا إنها
رائعة ومثل النجوم فوق
غور  يتألق نيرغرات في
وسط جبال الألب السويسرية
مما يبقي بوابة الفضاء مفتوحة
لسنوات عديدة قادمة
[موسيقى]